welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Katherine Lofton professor of
religious studies and American Studies
she's a historian of religion with a
particular focus on cultural and
intellectual history of the United
States through studies of preachers and
parents soap and office cubicles and
liberal theology professor Lofton has
developed a portrait of religion in
America that emphasizes the formation of
religion through new technologies
renegade manifestos and cornucopias of
cultural practices that contribute to
social identity in the modern world
today we'll talk with professor Lofton
about her first book Oprah the gospel of
an icon welcome professor lock down
thank you thank you so much for having
me well I'm very excited to have you
here today um I do love Oprah so I am
very excited to hear about your book
let's talk about it absolutely I mean
one of the main reasons I wrote the book
was because of that feeling that I would
met so many people throughout my life
who would say that so easily I love
Oprah how many things in culture do we
say that about Marilyn so unequivocally
this that's a good and that quickly made
me think about well what is good about
Oprah and that was the premise of my
research what makes us think there's a
good in her that we all want to follow
right so what is that good yeah one of
the key things I think I ended up
finding was that she wants to license
all of us to find the gospel of you and
that is to know that your best life is
the only path you need to follow hmm
get out of the way troubling men get out
of the way bad bosses get out of way
acne that makes you have low self-esteem
she's going to improve all parts of your
life and focus you on finding your best
you and my book tracks how she does that
through various public rituals and the
ways that she engages her audience to
participate with her and everything from
thinking through childhood traumas to
reading great works of literature to
doing mass nubra fittings so you can
find the right way to present
yourself in the world okay so how does
that tie into religion yeah one of the
theses of my book is to find another
single image in the United States or a
single figure that you would say
represents our religious now
sociologists have observed to three
major trends right now one very few
people would claim a single
denominational identity two people want
therefore the right to claim multiple
identities to say I'm a Jew but I am
really interested as well in yoga I'm
interested in yoga but sometimes I think
a Catholic funeral really makes sense of
the death I've experienced we want to be
able to mix and match and three we have
in general a great desire to find
personal happiness and that whatever
religious practices were taking up they
seem to be driven more often by the
pursuit of that happiness than an
understanding of a faraway deity and in
all three of those patterns
I think Oprah is the paragon she is the
representative of those trends and I
think is an icon of our present
religious age in the United States okay
so what about all of the atheists out
there don't that relate oh absolutely I
think is amazing because she seems to
anyone who watches her they make
arguments that she is them so an any
given day you can see Oprah talked about
a lot of different subjects but no
matter what the subject she's talking
about she always seems to be both
critical and trying to find belief again
so for the atheist that watch Oprah they
see a person who was once in a Christian
Church and talks very openly about being
in Baptist churches where she hated the
male leadership hated the doctrine hated
the rules and now she's found her own
way and her own independence so that
very idea to her rationalism got herself
out of a bad religious frame at the
classic plot of the atheist now Oprah
really wants to argue it out with
atheists and most recently had a very
public interview where a woman said you
know I'm an atheist and Oprah said no
you're not anyone with your kind of
spirit I can't not believe so Oprah
tends to think there is no such thing as
actual atheism there's just varieties of
expansive theism into what she would
argue all of us right right
okay so let's go back to some specific
examples of the effect of the Oprah
phenomena on religion in modern America
so I was thinking a lot about well I
want my first book to be when I was in
graduate school I wrote about late 19th
century religious people and the ideas
in the modern they had and for most
academics that's what you do you write a
first book based on your nerdy
dissertation research but when I went
out into the world we can became a
teacher I discovered that for students
the question of why that passed mattered
seemed to be a very big question why
should they care about Presbyterians in
the nineteenth century as I was having
that pedagogical experience I also
watched as we all did the ascent of
Barack Obama a person who I I feel I
write about in the book is very deeply
tied to the Oprah phenomenon in what way
so there's three ways I connect him
first is the absolute necessity of a
first-person narrative to enter public
life but the memoir is now gonna be the
key transaction the thing you give the
public to expose your sins but also
narrate your personal self into the myth
of America and his memoir and the
success of that is really being his
first bid into public office and that's
very similar of course to Oprah where
you know if you know anything about over
her beginnings you know very troubled
you know drug use you know as to her
meteor her great rise you know being a
multi media mogul billionaire and one of
the key things that allows her to do and
Obama to do is to say you have to always
remember I'm human and my the way in
which I continue to be a good leader for
you is I've been everywhere you've been
and the only difference between you and
me is I found a way to package it so it
doesn't bring me down it doesn't
continue to be a symptom it continues to
lift me up to say those those troubles
which gives you the space to in some
ways still be a sinner and I still
struggle in public but that's not
altogether true because there's a second
theme I want to bring up that brings
Oprah and and Obama together and that is
that they're both deeply committed to a
public civilizational project that that
the best self is one that looks put
together that has well-fitting clothes
that treats yourself with respect in
public and I think the kind of image of
the Obamas as a storm's iconic 50s era
family where
one's very well to rest there's no
misbehavior let's be clear sasha is not
on Facebook even the dogs are
well-behaved there's a sense of good
behavior as a sign of a good interior
and that that's one of the key lessons
of Oprah spiritual practice and Obama
also clearly endorses that and then
third I would say a resistance to
allowing concepts of difference to make
us different from one another so for
both Oprah and Obama they have a
profound desire to say we are all the
same our differences are only important
insofar as they tell us the particular
economic or social struggles but if
we're gonna come to any kind of
solutions we have to let go of those
differences and find our common humanity
and for Oprah that's why she's being a
little trapped I mean who would have
thought woman born in segregation South
a woman a very very poor origins would
become the image of middle class white
women in America who weep on her bosom
and tell them all her troubles well she
did that by saying I am just like you
there is no profound difference between
my blackness and your whiteness insofar
as we're both people who have suffered
because and then let's list out all
those little reasons that make life hard
those reasons in Oprah's world are never
critiques of economy or politics or
social stratification they're always
struggles the mind and the way that the
mind can recognize its best possibility
and Obama has a very similar message
which is why I think for some liberals
he's a frustrating leader because his
solutions are not always structural
Rivet isms he often asks us just be a
better you work harder for your country
and I'll do what I can but at the end of
the day Obama's not big government and
neither is Oprah mm-hmm okay let's talk
about Oprah's the school that she opened
up for girls in Africa how does that fit
into your book so I talk about that in a
chapter where I take up the question of
the mission as a concept of Oprah's life
but also a broader American religious
history there is a quotation by a great
American religious history scholar from
the early 20th century where he says
don't mistake yourself all Americans are
missionaries and makes a claim that to
be American is to be a very proposition
for come over here it's a better life
here and Oprah is just a beautiful icon
of that in her own tiny labors with
individual women but the school was born
of a
fantasy that I tie into a larger
african-american narrative of returning
to Africa and bringing the improvements
of the United States back there and so
she like a lot of late 19th century
african-american women who devoted
themselves to the missionary cause these
were one who are not returning to Africa
because they wanted to reclaim their
African as' they were returning to
Africa to bring Christianity and
American politics in American education
to them and so Oprah does this and I
described in detail the way that she
forms a school based very much off of
the desire of creating a perfect
physical space so much effort is put
into the physicality and as a contrast
to the girl she brings to the school who
she says come from these really
destitute in difficult material context
and I talk a lot about how in
contemporary geopolitics we think well
if you have the right sweater and a good
pair of jeans and the right books on
your lap you're gonna be better that
there's a kind of osmotic effect that
materials have especially those that
come from the United States and Oprah
definitely went into the project
thinking what these girls have is spirit
they're amazing but what they don't have
is good things so I'm gonna bring them
good knowledge and good things and
remake their lives but doesn't that fly
in the face of being not materialistic
how does that fit into the religious
aspect I know this is one of the hardest
things for people to take up when they
take up both Oprah's religion but also
contemporary American religious life
that for a lot of more liberal religious
thinkers there's something really
antithetical about the relationship
between materiality and spirituality but
Oprah is not alone in the history of
religions of seeing that there's a
profound connection between those two
things whether you think about the
Eucharist or worship a Hindu shrines
there's been a long tradition of making
a connection between materiality and
even prosperity as signs of spiritual
gifts and Oprah I like her in a
tradition of two things one evangelical
theology and particular prosperity
gospel theology which tells us that
those diamonds are a sign that he loves
you so if you've got them that's just a
sign of your own prosperity your own
excellence and the way that you're
giving something good to the world but
similarly I also linked her up to it a
train of something called New Thought
which is a spirituality movement that
happened in the late 19th century in
America that really emphasized how much
all materiality around you is a
representative spirit and so we can see
this into the contemporary environmental
movement where people talk about
remaking physical spaces to be more
environmentally responsible it's also
just having better feng shui better
spiritual energy around them but if my
house is no longer run by oil heat but
instead by forced air I'll just feel
better and new thought movement really
believe that too they were very into a
sort of whole health and in a sense that
there's a connection between the
material world and right spiritual
interior okay in your conclusion you're
right any descriptive iconic survey will
return to the same point to the
inseparability of consumer choice and
religious option in the modern period
what do you mean by that
yeah what I mean by that is is in my
field we've had a lot of debates about
what it means to call the contemporary
religious scene a marketplace is that a
criticism to say that people treat
religion like a set of consumer choices
I I myself don't find that to be a
problem I think that we live in a time
where people do conceive of their
religious life as a component of a
broader sphere of scheduling issues and
consumer issues and I think that over
the course of the 20th century we've
increasingly seen that the religions
that have survived the 20th century are
those that also understand the
marketplace as not a sight of resistance
but of participation and so I think of
the way evangelical megachurches often
have small mini malls attached to them
the way that anyone who wants to proper
spiritual advice has to find multiple
modes to communicate that to you for a
price
and I think Oprah is just a sort of
total encapsulation of the way that in
contemporary in a contemporary world we
don't want to have to decide is this
good or is this bad on the grounds of
consumption we decided consumption is
the way we enact our morality we live in
an era where what we buy what we text
what we like on Facebook are all
articulations I think of our ethics and
we're also articulations therefore of
our highest values whether or not we
like that that the consumer choice is
the formatting of our ethics is for a
philosophical debate I'm here to say
though that Oprah has embraced that and
said you know texting this number to get
five dollars to water in Africa she says
that's fine and I say most of American
religious people agree with her right
right okay so what then are the broader
implications of your book there are
three identify that I think as you look
forward you're always gonna see
religious actors continuing to
participate one is I think the end of
seeking to narrate God and instead the
endless desire to narrate the self a one
figure who's very iconic in this
tradition as a man named William James
wrote this book varieties of religious
experience and when he wrote this in the
early 20th century many people thought
it was so heretical because he spoke
about how individual narrative is really
what religious experience is articulate
as and that was a time where people
thought no religion is theology or it's
obedience to God we don't live in that
time anymore we live in William James's
world where narrating yourself your
first person's story is a part of the
primary idea of spiritual practice
second I think we are no longer going to
see us any kind of resistance to the
concept of consumption as being not
merely maybe an aspect of religious life
but its primary way of being articulated
I think we're gonna see the ways that
Facebook and other forms of social media
are going to be new forms of
congregation and those as spaces where
you can like and dislike and share
information without an obvious single
figurehead although Oprah is very
essential as a charismatic leader the
thing that her viewers most like is
being connected to goods connected to
other people who like these ideas these
books I think social media is
increasingly going to take the place of
our ideas of church hierarchy or church
organization and third I think we're
going to see increasingly the ways that
there is going to be no political or
economic program that will not be sold
to us without also having an
accompanying spiritual program so keep
an eye out for our leaders when they
want to tell us to go take up that war
in that faraway country or maybe have
this sort of austerity practice they're
always going to attach to it a sort of
this is good for you and therefore good
for humanity and they're gonna see
increasing language instead of god bless
america
pursuits of spirit you see already an
advertising culture how much advertising
culture talks about the spirit of you
and the spirit of your own life being
improved by the product
see this too in our leaders is they use
the language of spirituality to convince
us of projects they want to alert us to
so isn't just that Oprah lives in a
world I also think she has influenced
the world by suggesting that
spirituality as a helpful language to
get people to feel that the thing you're
selling is the thing they want Wow well
it certainly is a fascinating thing to
think about I have to say so thank you
so much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you so
much for more information about
Professor Lofton and her work please
visit our website at Yale dot edu /
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale